c'est une histoire d'amour qui a sali
barque de tragique mais il faut pouvoir
se fâcher pour se réconcilier et moi
j'essaie depuis que je suis président de
la république et même avant de regarder
notre passé en face je le fais sans
complaisance et donc j'entends souvent
au fond sur la question mémorielle la
question franco algérienne nous sommes
comme sommet en permanence de choisir il
faudrait dire
choisissez la fierté ou la repentance
moi je veux la vérité la reconnaissance
la vérité la reconnaissance il en avant
sera jamais moi je ne suis pas un enfant
de la guerre d'éleveurs ma famille non
plus mais je sais une chose la france ne
peut pas avancer sans
avancer sur ce sujet et l'algérie non
plus pourquoi parce que nos histoires
sont liées parce que la place que
représente l'algérie avec le nombre de
binationaux de français d'origine
algérienne
d'algériens vivant en france aujourd'hui
fait qu'il ya des millions de françaises
et de français ou binationaux qui sont
concernés par cette histoire si j'ajoute
à ça les harkis et leurs descendants et
rapatrier leurs descendants sont encore
plus de millions de français et c'est
pareil pour les jeunes nous avons été
ici pendant un cycle est donc cette
histoire on doit la regarder en face
avec courage
avec lucidité avec vérité c'est ce que
je fais depuis cinq ans et je le fais
d'abord et avant tout pour la france
parce que c'est la matrice du problème
mémorial que nous avons avec tentées
tant de pays je crois beaucoup de choses
ont été faites par nos historiens
ensuite politiquement comme jamais nous
ne l'avions fait ce que nous avons acté
ensemble y lire avec le président teboul
c'est une avancée à mes yeux qui est
historique aussi puisque pour la
première fois ensemble on a dit nous
allons mandater une commission mixte
d'historiens
cinq à six historiens de chaque côté